welcome to this video up some plain
beautiful mind from Switzerland Swiss
flag at least checked on Jackie let's
let's go robocop set up against the
Catalan it's a bit unusual but damn this
is a play with line I had this zone Jack
sim yellow line on the board in this um
classical time control tournament in
Austria that i won what deck um I
haven't canceled yet completely forgot
about that so we can know spoil my
castling rise to some lunch not noise I
was a bit more afraid about um set up
with f form yeah is playing it somewhat
later than I expected
hmm yeah how bad is this maybe it's not
so bad he's got the two bishops but it
is a fairly fairly solid position yeah
it's a very nice an idea no no no black
is better get them the better Bishop now
it's got potentially week pawns on the
girl the queenside threading a form and
you cannot really play um play it for
yourself yeah yeah you can just okay I
mean just them technically you can play
it it it's just not not particularly
great druke f8 intending look every this
end game is very nice for black I'm
going to prevent him too many of those
ok so how to how to make progress some
what a question is me and maybe it is
solid enough for whiteheads I really
it's really unpleasant for what but
maybe it's not lost
okay probably the only way to make any
headway as possible is on the King side
I'm always attacking the b3 porn okay
interesting should I place you five
hmm
okay i do need to do this immediately
yeah it's probably a drone
it's not hard to see why using
yeah it's how to how to do now
that's probably it's probably just too
close to this position okay
maybe I can try to get to the Jeep on 5i
fatigue on g3 just due to this pawn some
nice time and IDM
cannot play Bishop g4 is cody for and
I'm blundering it so not a good idea I'm
what about g5 you please g4 is the
special trapped possible
and we can play f ing for this is a
fortress it's a very passive of course
but still winning
hmm yeah probably exchange too much yeah
disposal it wasn't enough to get to win
it's a very problematic setup for white
and he's really um yeah asking for it a
bit but it was solid enough gras Alfred
gras Alfred Gras Alfred game drawn yeah
this wasn't particularly exciting what
can you do I thought I I would this this
end game would promise pretty good
winning chances so why this was a miss
miss judgment or maybe how do i need to
do it in some some other way
yeah maybe it's not enough simply the
King on c3 just keeps keeps everything
together yeah that's probably just the
wrong those pants are always a problem
in relation to them to the bishop but
sometimes very difficult to make any
progress if you have a bishop itself
with the night at some that's it's
different yeah this means that here I
shouldn't exchange looks maybe maybe try
to do something else here's some we
cannot do anything constructive anyway
maybe you try i don't know maybe h5 or
something this is this kind of ideas
it's just very slightly better for black
but not not decisive probably all right
not very exciting thanks for watching
anyway